-And now it's time for
"Donald J. Trump
and the Big Beautiful Wall."
There once was a President
named Donald J. Trump.
Donald loved to build things,
like skyscrapers
and an angry fan base.
But the one thing
he never got to build
was a big, beautiful wall.
The country said it was
a bad idea that wasted money,
and that made Donald mad.
So that night before bed,
he kneeled and prayed.
-Dear Colonel Sanders,
I wish for the biggest,
most beautiful wall
for my border.
-The next morning, he woke up
and turned on Fox News,
and here it was --
a brand-new wall on the border.
Donald flew on Air Force One
to meet it,
and when he got there,
he couldn't believe his eyes.
The wall was 20 feet high,
hundreds of miles long,
steel, but concrete,
solid, but slats.
Donald hugged the wall
and exclaimed...
-Hello, my big, beautiful wall.
Will you be my best friend?
-Of course!
-...said the wall.
-We will be best friends
and go on many adventures!
Hop on!
-So Donald jumped on the wall's
back and off they flew.
-Let's go fight
the Great Wall of China.
-...said Trump.
The wall laughed.
-[ Laughs ]
I can't go there.
I have to fight crime
here in America.
I have a better idea.
-...said the wall
as it turned on its side
and dipped down into
the Rio Grande River.
-I could be the world's biggest
waterslide!
-Wee!
-...Donald exclaimed as he
slid down into the water.
-Oh, no.
Oh, I forgot I can't swim.
Help me, wall.
-...shouted Donald.
But the wall couldn't help him
and flew away.
-Sorry, Donald.
I'm off to stop refugee children
from crossing the border!
-As Donald flailed in the water,
he woke up
flailing in bed.
Was it all a dream?
Donald quickly turned on
Fox News
and saw that there was no
big, beautiful wall.
Sad!
So Donald took
an executive time nap
so he could once more
go on adventures
with his best friend, the wall,
in his dreams.
♪♪